Okulun resim atölyesinde, dolabın kenarında tahta bir kukla asılıydı.
Mira onu indirdi.
Kolu tıkırdayarak büküldü.
Kuklayı masaya oturttu ve elini çekti.
Kukla olduğu yerde yığıldı.
Mira ise sabahtan beri ayaktaydı ve yığılmamıştı.
Peki insanı ayakta tutan şey neydi?
Cevap üç kahramanda saklıydı.
Kemikler, eklemler ve kaslar.
Mira kuklayı alıp fen sınıfına geçti.
Köşedeki iskelet modeli, kuklanın büyümüş hali gibi duruyordu.
Yetişkin bir insanda yaklaşık 206 kemik bulunur.
Kemikler vücuda şeklini verir ve onu ayakta tutar.
Bir de en önemlisi, yumuşak organları korurlar.
Kafatası beyni sert bir kutu gibi çevreler.
Kaburgalar, kalbinle akciğerlerin önünde kafes kurar.
Mira modelin uyluk kemiğini yerinden çıkardı.
Avcundan uzundu.
Kemikleri şekillerine göre üç gruba ayırıyoruz.
Uzun kemikler kollarda ve bacaklardadır.
Uyluk kemiği en uzunudur.
Kısa kemiklerin eni ve boyu birbirine yakındır.
El ve ayak bileklerimizde bu küçük kemiklerden onlarca vardır.
Yassı kemikler levha gibidir.
Kafatası, kaburga ve leğen kemiği böyledir.
Mira üç kemiği yan yana dizdi.
Hiçbiri diğerine benzemiyordu.
Peki bu kadar kemik birbirine nasıl bağlanıyordu?
Mira atölyenin kapısını yavaşça itti.
Kapı, menteşesinin üstünde sessizce döndü.
Kemiklerin birleştiği yerlere eklem diyoruz.
Eklemler tıpkı bir menteşe gibi çalışır.
Onları hareket yeteneklerine göre üçe ayırırız.
Oynar eklemler kollarda ve bacaklardadır.
Rahatça hareket ederler.
Mira dizini bükünce eklem menteşe gibi açılıp kapandı.
Yarı oynar eklemler omurgada bulunur.
Hareketleri kısıtlıdır.
Öne doğru eğilebiliriz ama omurga bir kapı gidip atlanmaz.
Oynamaz eklemler kafatasındadır ve asla hareket etmezler.
Oradaki kemikler birbirine adeta kaynamıştır.
Kemikler ve eklemler tamamdı ama kuklayı ne hareket ettirecekti?
Kuklanın eklemleri vardı ama onları çeken hiçbir şey yoktu.
Mira kolunu büktü ve kolunun üstü sertleşip kabardı.
İşte motor buydu, kaslar.
Kaslar kasılırken kısılır ve bağlı olduğu kemiği kendine çeker.
Gevşediğinde kemik eski yerine döner.
Vücudumuzda üç çeşit kas vardır.
Çizgili kaslar yani iskelet kasları isteğimizle çalışır.
Hızlıdırlar ama çabuk yorulurlar.
Düz kaslar isteğimiz dışında kendiliğinden çalışır.
Mide ve bağırsak gibi iç organlarımızda bulunurlar.
Yavaştırlar ama yorulmazlar.
Kalp kası ise yalnızca kalpte bulunur.
Şekli çizgili kasa benzer, çalışması düz kasa.
Ömrümüz boyunca hiç durmadan çalışır.
Sağlıklı bir destek ve hareket sistemi için duruşumuza dikkat etmeliyiz.
Süt ve yoğur gibi karsiyumlu besinler kemikleri güçlendirir.
Bir de bol bol hareket etmek gerekir.
Mira kuklayı yerine astı.
Bu sefer hareket eden oydu.